five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
genius brain podcast we just knocking
him out today man you have any idea that
you guys are actually very highly
requested on this podcast which is
insane because there are way more
important people there like you know who
I like I like the [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
that's what I love about it's about it's
about the people it's not about the
clout which I hate that word clouds
clouds clouds weird sound like it
represents what it means you know as
opposed to is supposed to hurt people
like to make [ __ ] like I feel like
intelligent words sound unintelligent
mm-hmm like when they call a girl a
female like females supposed to be the
smart award for girl but like look at
this females like now it just sounds
hood yeah don't like you ASMR [ __ ] I
don't like it why do you watch ASMR so
oh here's the thing I get ASMR let me
said you say this before I [ __ ] on you
and make fun of you
I like ASMR back crack's like when they
get your chiropractic [ __ ] cuz it
reminds me of me getting my back cracked
so it helps me relax so I used to watch
that [ __ ] all the time but you like
people like chewing on [ __ ] no it's not
the sounds it's just like the that is
what a Simone is the right sounds yeah I
know but it's not most it's about people
eating like this disgusting [ __ ] crab
leg and it was the nastiest even this
[ __ ] cool hey I would never start a
conversation by saying hey this is cool
I would never do that first off second
this whole ASMR thing it just it's one
of those things that's like a car
accident it's like so [ __ ] gross and
it's uh it's gross watching people eat
large amounts of food or stock is
getting lower and lower as your speech
700 it's like a car accident guy you
know when you laugh at it and then
you're like haha [ __ ] people dying
like everybody explaining that they like
step [ __ ] brother porn yes they're
not really really yeah yeah exactly it's
like I would love to be my step-brother
yep you could have said stepsister but
oh no no I that's a that's a slip
no there's anything wrong with that if
you like [ __ ] no I just think it's gross
and I for some reason I just can't stop
watching it
that's what it is I'm not like one type
all right what type of like cuz I
understand because I think mukbang
started for people who eat alone and so
they want to eat with some people oh
that's a thing bro hey that's what it is
I like seeing people you liked on big ol
bowl of noodles I'm like a man cuz I
imagine me eating the bowl noodles they
loved it did
and so it's me just seeing people eat
like fatty shitty food that I can have
like so a lot of it got big because a
lot of people who were on diets would
like watching other people eat the food
they can't eat which to me is torture I
want to see you eat a [ __ ] bowl of
broccoli and hate it cuz I'm like hey
you're me baby yeah I like that bull I
like watching people eat ramen I'm like
ah man like really I don't know I don't
know why I just like you're a creep bro
that's problem solve we've figured it
out y'all but I have a hos weirdest [ __ ]
I have a buddy who does ASMR [ __ ] now
and she did it and she's like she's more
popular on her ASMR channel that she
just started recently than her actual
channel well what's her actual channel
it's like Fitness stuff and just daily
vlog stuff she was like she's like a
fitness person and then she did the ASMR
thing and it's doing way better it's
just her like it's a niche though you
know and this you could literally hear
her swallow her spit yeah see that's
kind of soothing that like jerking off
to this or like we're falling into it
it's supposed to make them fall asleep I
don't know if this is like it I was like
is this sexual is this what is this
because there's a lady like I don't know
if you guys have seen the bread face
lady have you ever seen that yeah that's
what the [ __ ] I don't know who
this is actually I [ __ ] with this
because I think it's hilarious yeah but
like it's some lady like dare you judge
this bad way let me explain myself the
girl in her face inbred it's so brioche
it's like she'll be at a table sometimes
she's in public or what the one at the
beach the last one I saw was at the
beach she has a different piece of bread
every time and she just sticks her face
in it and just mashes her face to the
the surface of the table whatever it is
and that's the whole [ __ ] video and
it has like millions of likes but it's
it's so funny to me because it's like
why do I feel like this person's Asian
she might be corrected on Korean she
looks like she's Korean but Chinese yeah
she was I think she was like that was
like a big story that was the one that
everybody was talking about like oh my
god this girl makes X amount of dollars
a day way money from how people donate
money towards Twitter well people were
at her might and they'll give a request
they'll give her a request like hilari
do a croissant do a chocolate croissant
and she'll do it and they'll pay her to
do it
what yeah some talk I could do that will
you guys pay me money to smash bread in
my face cuz I do it anyways I'll eat my
food like a pig tricked into a trough
it's always like just a stale face like
she has no emotion and it's just like
it'll start like it'll be a loaf of
bread and for some reason I see her
smashing her face into it full force
like Mach 10 and but that would be
[ __ ] happy with every way she comes
up it's just the bloody nose he's
smoking to the bredis of those jobs
absorbs the moisture but she like she
gets every part of her face I think
he'll send it to us it's weird I think
it's funny as [ __ ] it makes me laugh see
there's entertainment into it your thing
is what you what do you do to it
you just enjoy it no I just I send it to
my other buddies I'm like dude look at
this [ __ ]
I sent to all the people eating noodles
yeah I send them sup well it's like
there's a guy that I really like he's in
pain dude like he takes the biggest like
bowl of noodles and just eats it and his
his mouth is his cheeks are full he's
still chewing and then he takes a giant
piece of like stink
eat that busting it's it's so disgusting
and I'll send it to my to the guys that
I work with shots on my co-workers at
PSC I'll send them videos and we'll just
send each other videos like oh my you
know I talk straight about this but I've
done like seven month bangs on my
channel before but then it was - I did
it in my David's o-type okay it's your
boy was exhausting his [ __ ] so I set up
three cameras I would eat the food
describe words from and it'll be like
the top three best sandwiches in LA but
that's different though that's like
you're giving in yeah this is just like
just eating food yeah but but like
suffering it's only good it's really
good on Instagram like if you ask me to
go on youtube and watch it and I'm like
you're better than them huh you sick son
of a [ __ ] he's like a weird moral
high-ground only good for ten seconds
dude I'd only [ __ ] do it on Instagram
all right yeah Tommy you know those
youtubers dude no yeah I'm not jerking
off to this this is this is guy that's
really big on he does like mukbang stuff
- he cooks the food and he eats it but
the way he eats the food makes me want
to find him and stab him the eyes he is
chew so [ __ ] loud I don't yeah and
that's how he chews and it's like bro
shut your [ __ ] mouth you disgusting
[ __ ] I will find you and kill you that's
how much I hate them dude there's
there's these people that take like a
bunch of razor clams and they're all
from like they're from I think they're
Chinese for sure why and then they they
put them all together like this and
they're they're dipped in like chili oil
like that like them the mouth numbing
ones and they fit it in their mouth
these chew on them they suck out the
razor clams dude and it's like oh my god
what is this dog my favorite [ __ ]
cooking one dude by the way is this one
Asian Channel I'll send it to you guys
later hilarious cook it's not supposed
to be hilarious but this guy cooks
everything in a wok at his restaurant
but he literally has the live animal and
it's like the most obscure animal ever
he's like today we have a wood rat
running around and he just chops up the
[ __ ] live wood rat no way why does
the camera and he took out an in your
videos he took that part out because I
guess it's too graphic yeah but it'll be
like the most today we have dueling
style scarecrow
cooling style why are you cooking these
weird animals that you're not supposed
to [ __ ] eat it's like it's a wooden
man wooden man it's the weirdest [ __ ]
it's like today we have wombat I'm like
where did you capture this he goes it's
very Australian being in my family
recipe for 200 years it's like your
family has been anyone bad for 200 years
you [ __ ] sick [ __ ] this guy just has
an excuse to just kill animals did you
spit every animal that you think you
shouldn't eat he cooks it and it's
delicious apparently it's it's like and
it's all in [ __ ] Mandarin and it
makes me laugh
what's located Cantonese what's the
craziest food you've eaten animal was uh
I think I had pig uterus before which I
didn't know those pig uterus cuz it was
like in a hot pot okay and I ate it I
was like it was a weird [ __ ] and then
like me you know inside the the pig is
the womb and I got the guy who was
telling me what it was he was nervous to
tell me cuz I just ate this [ __ ] and
here he knew I was gonna hate it here
that you know the pot weirdo it looked
like a clam on a girl it's like a clay
you know guy have a hot dog you have a
taco this way you come from this oink
oink [ __ ] [ __ ]
I've eaten grubs like an Ecuador like
the long yellow like the [ __ ] lame oh
the one that just [ __ ] squiggling it
were like it looked gross how was it it
was like eggs kind of like scrambled
eggs oh really yeah pretty good it was a
bad it's just that it's just the texture
and the fact that you see well he was
wrong
yeah a wrong wha what's wrong with you I
just it was an echo baby come on
no why because he was already prepped
from that Dookie dick yeah yeah yeah
take that shoutout to the first episode
for the first time Duke edict out baby I
have a mutant once you smell Dookie big
dude you're just like nothing affects me
a stay tuned for the divorce you guys
gonna find out about this
it tastes like scrambled eggs it kind of
tastes like scrambled eggs what then I
tried fried ones and in live ones
I bet the fry ones were bread no they
were better because it's
we it is weird nice little crunch like
we all about you would you eat right a
cricket you can't offer anything to a
conversation what do you have my dad's
you actually beat all of us but I never
I never ingested it so doesn't matter
eyes look dumb some of it all those
girls in that are Kelly tape being
ingested either and you're one of them
know what can I say I'm amongst legends
dude I wonder what happened mr Kelly got
a hand at you he would have had his way
with you yeah your brother's probably
especially like I'm gonna piss in your
mouth you like already done it about two
years ago he would know I know you drink
piss before thank you see I can see the
only smell it happy I'll be like all
right mr. Kelly let's do this
unknowingly I'd be like all right okay
that's [ __ ] disgusting you're a weird
guy man go with the flow baby tinkle
tinkle baby I do you like the weird
mukbang stuff I think that's the part
that creeps me out about what just like
the just like morbidly obese people
eating which I don't know I don't like
that it's like two years ago that was be
the pain that's why I'm telling you in
wartime he's snapping like he likes the
for-sure ring he likes the suffering
element no it's not the suffering it's
just like it's funny to see one lady was
suffering with the crab legs like it was
bad I was like that was a bad aborting
video and I didn't dipping it in like
melted butter the ashes you guys don't
watch waterboarding videos those are my
favorite videos no basis of debt I know
I said I don't edit my podcast but we're
gonna no we're gonna keep it on actually
it's a videos now because it doesn't
take much time yeah it's actually pretty
quickly use it lay over the audio and
you go done you've never cut anything
for a pocket
I've cut certain parts but I felt like
maybe you shouldn't have said that
because it's about their private life
like now we'll cut that [ __ ] hush but I
try not to make cut that's why we only
have one camera come on man
yeah I tried multiple cameras people
hated it and I was like thank you
because it was a lot of [ __ ] work
yeah I don't think they like the jumping
it's too erratic they just want to see
it kind of makes them feel like they're
a part of the room when they're just
right there in the corner hmm yeah
that's fair over there in the corner
your opinion matters
this podcast is brought to you by
Skillshare my friends if you are into
lifelong learning that you are into
skill shares there's something out there
in the twenty twenty new year that you
were thinking that hey I should probably
tackle well guess what I've been using
skills shared for quite a while now when
it comes to anything videography or
photography wise I use Skillshare to
sharpen up my skills and I know a lot of
you out there want to learn at your own
time and at your own pace well guess
what skill share has a huge database of
knowledge that you could pick from and
get you sharpening up those skills to
day my friends so skill share is a proud
sponsor of genius brain explore your
creativity at Skillshare comm slash
brain and get to three months of premium
membership that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free get started and joined today by
heading to skill shared calm slash brain
that skill share calm slash brain your
opinion man speaking of opinions man
topic of the day ricky gervais co me
bang bang bang bang bang did you guys
ever watch any of Ricky Gervais zuzana
standup yeah I used I we were just
talking about it outside
we're title one where he did the Noah's
Ark hey everything that one he talks it
he talked about like the Bible for like
the whole special and he just breaks
down like it's really funny I'm not
gonna even do it justice but I think
it's not you do I want you to ruin his
stand-up please do it alright my name is
no I'm not gonna do that but no Ricky
Gervais is [ __ ] hilarious like how
he's like the [ __ ] medieval pest
I know I just have a couple of shillings
but please could you get me some water
you could have been in the game of
Thrones I would love you know what the
funny thing is I really wanted to be in
the game of Thrones but I'm pretty sure
I would have been like somebody's Asian
sex some random [ __ ] Asian guy and
Game of Thrones is like what is he he's
some [ __ ] [ __ ] creature eyes are
small because he's always looking into
the light let's review all of Game of
Thrones starting from Season one go
ahead okay first season was trashed
second season not great number three the
red wedding
let's want to start a poppin baby once
you stab a pregnant woman in the fetus
that's what's up that's what I like Oh
no-holds-barred do you do whatever and
they kept showing it away well this is
finally something my speed I [ __ ]
John Snow was interesting Johnson was
doe I that way that [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
was terrible yeah and ruined the whole
series awful the night king episode was
sick but that should have been like the
last episode and also that dude
shouldn't have died that easy yeah it
was like that episode though was when I
was washing I was [ __ ] my pants yeah
yeah they should have ended it with that
yeah it was like brandy man was useless
that dude doesn't do anything all
dessert she dies really lame yeah I
heard Cersei wasn't actually naked in
the walk of shame it was a body double
and they [ __ ] deep fake her face on
this year did they do that with
Targaryen but I think in this gang she
was naked and then they went she wasn't
I don't want to be naked any more
respect she got her she got yeah she's
doing her thing that's when I watched
that first episode and the people just
naked a Mike who's a good show I don't
know why it [ __ ] held off on this
[ __ ] something else dick this is a great
show Theon Greyjoy did you I think you
just imagine that in your fantasy just
talk about his dick be mad his dick dude
they do not show his dick and you are
[ __ ] guys in the comments below
talk about when Theon Greyjoy showed
they did not show his dick they made a
lot of references to how big it was for
his size is my mouth watering ah geez
this guy has saved so much sus [ __ ]
right now dance stepbrothers Theon
Greyjoy he's probably my crush on the
show what were you saying
my crushes my bag hey can we edit that I
would love to be I love many the reason
why I like Game of Thrones well for the
first two seasons were a little whack
for me but I liked it because I just
like swords and I liked that medieval
[ __ ] I loved that old show Hercules with
Kevin Sorbo Xena princess yeah with Lucy
Lawless and then Kevin Suzy Louis dude I
remember I was watching that movie with
a buddy like my buddy's dad is Chilean
dude who had a crazy bad temper and you
would always watch like just Bruce Lee
movies and cowboy movies it's like all
he did and for some reason we were
watching another movie with that guy
Brian what's his name the [ __ ] Brian
what Okemos or mo Kevin Sorbo or
whatever and it's like a movie about
detectives or something and he's like
can't go and it's as like come on
[ __ ] breakout I have ghost your
heart girlie he's always Hercules like
it's a different role it's not real man
40s you're [ __ ] Hercules dog but God
are those that cuz they ain't [ __ ] dog
doesn't understand how movies work
that's so [ __ ] funny it's just so
unreal man he's Hercules he can't break
out of those things like you know that
shit's not real bro cuz he's like when
he goes to [ __ ] Greece he's
disappointed he goes where's all the
[ __ ] to God
where's Aphrodite where Zeus yeah that's
a lady that's so [ __ ] funny that's
dedication and Kevin Sorbo was the [ __ ]
man I see like perky leaves and then
Xena Warrior Princess because I thought
Lucy laws was hot and she also had her
lesbian lover Gabrielle on that yeah
they actually made out on that show oh
they that was his I remember this scene
specifically because I tried to
masturbate it to later when I was older
like two days yesterday she died and
that she found the Fountain of Life and
for some reason instead of just putting
the water into her mouth she decides to
drink the water and then put the water
in her mouth through her mouth and I as
a kid maybe we're like my bottoms are
tinkling yeah yeah what what is this
sensation I like it when tools at your
first transfer I don't remember what my
first boner was but I do remember the
first time when I masturbated and I came
and it hurt yeah I was like oh
yeah it kind of hurt a little bit Wow I
did this the first time when I was when
I came I went I just forgot oh geez I
thought I was peeing
you put the top down yeah I went topped
it off did it help and it went back in
and yeah yeah come on lovey you got like
CTE [ __ ] yeah sometimes
yeah I'm it's late I'm sleepy right
James totally talking about it talk
about fall asleep I'm sleepy right now
yeah you know what it's not even that
late dude dude I must sleep by though
really what time is it right now
it's 1008 you sleep at 10 o clock dude
Tiff's already sleeping she's right
she's waiting for me to come home and
wrap this up dude I'm just like let's go
through the Ricky Gervais
transcript okay baby because that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] wild pull it up baby I
thought it was offensive and I didn't
like it
oh sure - is there a pineapple on you
sure there's a pineapple eating a shark
or a shark eating a pineapple I can't
balance it yes let's start with the
Ricky Gervais think for you guys from
you with the accent it with the accent
oh I can't yeah but see the way I do the
the whatever the European British accent
is very offensive apparently is it
people get mad at you I don't think it's
real that's why because you know like
there's like different regions but yeah
we talk we always choose like the most
obnoxious whatever I mean mom doesn't
speak like that we always choose Jason
Statham that's right but you know what
that means my English yeah when English
people make fun of Americans it's always
like valley girl or something like or
they go yeah man real cool bad love my
hot cars and we Trump I love it I love
me guns
bang bang my American also wears be
[ __ ] car I'm Jason Statham [ __ ]
car I'm going to hurt you and I'm going
to rip your eyes out that's transporter
yep awesome I don't know why I'm killing
but I'm just doing it
I'm doing it for the [ __ ] of it the the
part that everybody loved I think that
they were quoting about a Ricky Gervais
is [ __ ] was that one statement right
before he [ __ ] left what'd he say he
goes oh he thought first it was he led
into the Apple thing when he was
[ __ ] look this was the best party
goes Apple roared into the TV game with
the morning show
a superb drama a superb drama about the
importance of dignity and doing the
right thing my company that runs
sweatshops in China [ __ ] burned yeah
they jump out of buildings and they put
nets on them so well
you say you're woke but the companies
you work for I mean unbelievable Apple
Amazon Disney if Isis started the
streaming service you'd call your agent
what did you do that was so if you do
win an award tonight please don't use it
as a platform to make a political speech
you're in no position to lecture the
public about anything you know nothing
about the real world most of you spent
less time in school than Greta Thun Berg
so if you win come up accept your little
award thank your agent and your God and
[ __ ] off beautiful that [ __ ] is so true
beautiful is so [ __ ] true so true and
and like four years as needed have been
like this someone needed to tell these
[ __ ] that forever it's weird
when I when there's like like
presidential debates or stuff about
politics in the gut which by the way
it's very deep and it's very hard to
understand and they had this resounding
like tweet about what you should do
about politics and also the [ __ ] when
it's like do what do you know yeah you
are an actor and you are a gajillion air
it's like what are you [ __ ] talking
about and the funny thing is to the the
people who really hate Trump right and
these people who are make a [ __ ] ton of
money you guys are the ones that are
actually benefiting the most that Trump
is the office you are getting the
fattest [ __ ] tax breaks because of
his tax break policies based on your
bracket of income which is so [ __ ]
odd to me which is this is what he's
talking about it's like you talk all
this [ __ ] but you're the one that's
benefiting from all this stuff but you
want to talk about this moral high
ground
look you shut the [ __ ] up and I agree
now if I was there just one of
me too and people actually went nuts too
people went crazy for for Tom Hanks he
was sweating bullets I know that school
at all
Tom Hansen he use like like dude you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz the cameras on him the whole time so
he knows he has to like kind of save
face probably but you know it I think a
lot of these guys a lot of the the were
they pan to the people in the audience
they were all [ __ ] just I think they
were all really nervous man yes do they
were super pissed like that you're
[ __ ] up my paycheck yeah the the joke
he said about Judi Dench know the the
joke he said about James Corden
oh god my fat [ __ ] like yeah
hilarious play the fat [ __ ] and he was
also me classic boom bang bang I
guarantee you Jimmy's gonna do a
response about that is he fat shaming is
not something not like James Corden no I
think people love James Corden so the
thing is I think like I think he's a
very progressive guy so people who are
on the farm right they don't really like
sarios but James Corden seems like a
really cool dude you know like what I do
like about him is the fact that like how
successful he became and how he found
his Lane really well yeah like he's a
really great late-night host that's like
his [ __ ] [ __ ] but I think like some
people felt he was a little I guess
somebody made I it was him talking about
the subject of being like something
about fat shaming and then he did this
whole statement about a lot of people
love them but when you have such a harsh
stance on something the other side of it
people will get mad yeah and I guess
like you know the whole fat shaming
topic is like where do we draw the line
from what fat shaming is and just people
just wanting to live an unhealthy
lifestyle right cuz I mean I've I was
270 [ __ ] pounds yeah right so like I
understand what it is to be fat I think
it's very weird cuz even though I was
fat I never said like healthy man I
wasn't walking around trying to give
people life advice about what healthy is
and I never convoluted like loving
myself with being healthy I was a fat
[ __ ] like I could barely breathe like I
remember when I was walking down the
stairs I felt everything jiggle and I
was like I don't think my body should
feel this way yeah yeah you know I mean
my knees would hurt I had trouble
[ __ ] sleeping my
owls let's talk about poopy baby we're
that fat diarrhea all day like I said
when diarrhea is every day it's just
poop that's what it is baby but it's
weird when they're like yet and you know
people have like these very arbitrary
arguments when it comes to health and
being big big oh you can't judge
somebody based on their weight on their
athleticism very [ __ ] true yeah you
really can't right because there's power
lifters [ __ ] very large but they're
squatting a gazillion pounds but they
also can't tie their shoes exactly I
mean there's people who there are these
stuff but I think sometimes a lot of
people like to find the exception to the
rule so it can apply to them yeah yeah
right and that's the weird part for me
it's like listen you're 350 pounds
you're 5 foot 8 you're unhealthy they're
like well you don't know I could be
athletic trust me you're not you're not
your leg looks like cottage cheese and
you're also 14 so let's figure this [ __ ]
out all right it so it's okay for you to
say like I'm unhealthy and I'm okay with
it but you can't tell somebody that
you're healthy just because you want to
say that you're healthy or that they're
an [ __ ] for pointing that out yeah
like like that's the thing is like if
you like I mean I don't know if they
mean like because it's weird to not be
able to just say what the [ __ ] the
reality is it's like it doesn't make you
an inferior person if you're if you're
fat right like it's just it doesn't make
you less of a human being that's
actually yeah you're taking a more
[ __ ] space I can say this I'm fat fat
people can make fun of fat people until
I'm skinny I could keep doing it but
like bro like what the [ __ ] like I have
someone people make fun of each other
all the time for everything like yeah
it's I you're like your feelings don't
like come before everybody else's or
everything else in the world like it's
not you know if I was playing to the fat
person side you know because I'm a
bigger guy like I I understand because
like you know it's the easiest thing to
get made fun of and that's like to
always go to jokes so I could see why
people get feel belittled when they're
bigger right yeah that's also like stuff
to wear just things just aren't catered
towards bigger people which for me I
never understood it's like you know if
you want to make more money make some
[ __ ] clothes for fatter people
there's a lot of fat people in the world
there's some clothes for that fat people
need to lose weight if you have Fitness
stuff and like you did a good job they
made clothes for fat people they weren't
taking a moral stance but it's a
business thing it's like you know fat
people need to lose weight they
you got to start somewhere so they need
some fitness [ __ ] kind of makes sense so
I understand trust me I get it as a fat
person I understand like how it sucks to
be fat and out everybody pokes fun at
you at it you know not everybody's gonna
be like me where I'm just like riding
dis is back it's like [ __ ] just
wait till you talk about my titties I'm
talking about your divorce how about you
divorce parents no game dude yeah it's
fair game so you know there's there's
ways that I cope with it and that's not
everybody but yeah I just I just think
it's weird that we're having this
conversation that you know fat is
healthy and III that's just the one
little thing I don't like is I don't
want people to think that your worth is
it's not it's not a self value thing
it's just scientific [ __ ] fact you're
going on a treadmill do some blood work
how about that yeah if we just do blood
work we look at your [ __ ] and your
cholesterol is through the [ __ ] roof
like your blood work says that you're
you're very deficient in certain things
you're unhealthy you have fucked-up
joints and [ __ ] like that
and and then the argument is that I'm
still a good person I'm still beautiful
nobody's talking about that [ __ ]
right yeah yeah we're just saying that
you're unhealthy mm-hmm and I also think
- it's a from an animal point it does
make sense that people are attracted to
more fit people I think just as just as
that's how it is in the nature no in the
nature that's what they say when you see
Pilate I go like the big tiger that's
what I say that yeah and it yeah it's
it's sends the point home for sure
because like I guess like for you
because you're your I believe you work
in Fitness from what I recollect not
anymore haven't financed now oh well
here finance now I know that I'm a
custodian at a financial office pick up
pennies off the floor yeah I'm doing
really good this week well I mean I
guess for you because you're in fitness
like how do you deal with that because I
think I feel like sometimes like a lot
of personal trainers they have to see
people who come in and they're not very
open and honest about what their goals
are and what they want yeah they're like
I the first thing like I always hear
people is they go like listen I [ __ ]
loved over the way I am I love this [ __ ]
but the first thing they want to do is
talk about like how they look and how
they don't feel great so I don't
understand
what are you getting it like is it this
way or that way yeah
a lot of times it's a it's very
objective right so my client base is
very different for the most part I get a
lot of like skinnier dudes I just want
to put on muscle or things like that but
for the most part it's it's the same
approach across the way and a lot of it
we don't progress forward unless there
is and we analyze kind of what you're
here for and we have to really dig deep
on what your goals are cuz a lot of
times people come in and they don't want
to admit why they're really there mm-hmm
you know it does take a lot of
conversation a lot of times it's like
they have to feel comfortable with me
right
Oh for them to open up for them to open
up because like I've had people come in
and they're like yeah I just you know
actually get stronger I just want to
kind of just like do a little more mm
classic answer you know it's just like
yeah just yeah like my wife tells me I
need to work out I was like 5 pounds
let's just just love ya or or just buy
ounces yeah you know I just yeah yeah
yeah so it's then it then it comes down
to uh how many ounces do you want to
lose 3 ounces this cool 630 steak ya
know so it's it's it's a lot of it is
bring self awareness people like I I
feel like every time I come on here to
talk about that because it that's the
biggest thing it's understanding what
people are doing currently and what they
can do to change their normal habits
right sometimes people pay me money to
try to help them fix things and
sometimes they just they can't get it
done just because they can't come to
reality with themselves which is a
problem that everybody has whether it's
a fitness or or business or whatever
records it's just something that
everybody has a fundamental problem with
because people don't want to face what
their real issues are yeah you know you
know when I when I started losing weight
and then a couple of friends were asking
me how I did it because I tried for
multiple years and I failed constantly
and that's all my fault right because
I'd like burgers you know it's like and
at the time that meant more to you it
did it meant way more to me I was like I
want this burger and not deal but thigh
real exactly I just need 16 wipes just
swipe swipe swipe
I'm good to go wasted a lot of toilet
paper in my life Ellen let me tell you
come on come on go [ __ ] when there was
some blood in that stool I was like
maybe it's time to change my life
Seco so that's that's what it is right
like what's scarier than finding blood
in your [ __ ] I were like Oh what did I
do
I was wiping too much from all this just
tearing skin out my anus dude I had a
butt hole of a pornstar how about that
is just because I just new skin nice new
skin bleached white like the hairs off
his [ __ ] that's a party was wiping it
just felt like Bert matches keep your
[ __ ] clean you know that's what it
was that's what it is yeah you know I
like I have a friend right now she's uh
like I give her gave her the same stuff
that I did to kind of help me there yeah
but then I always told her to it's like
no matter what I give you if you're not
committed to make this change it's not
gonna make a [ __ ] difference because
at the other day the information is
already out there yeah is there right
there's when people hire me I'm not
trying to like I my goal my end goal is
sort of try to teach them as much as I
can yeah not just tell them what to do
because sometimes people just need to
hire someone just to tell them what to
do but at the end of it it's like how do
I get this person to do to walk once a
week yeah sure than they already do like
what is it to them like how can I tap
and that's what a lot of it is it's just
like it's just changing behavior right
and a lot of times people don't want to
do it we're in a world to where I think
everybody wants like isn't it
gratification exact people think what it
is it's entitlement I'm all right that
entitlement baby exactly like like
people uh they think they're owed
something or they think they deserve
something but at the other day like no
one really owes you anything you know so
and a lot of times people don't want to
get their hands dirty and trust me I've
been there done that I remember the
first time I tried I went to the MMA gym
that I started at I was like oh [ __ ]
like I'm gonna get this [ __ ] in like a
month bra like I'm a quick learner
everyone thinks that in their head like
oh I'm a quick learner hey you were a
little cocky [ __ ] yeah do it I was like
man I was I was made to do well by the
way first month yeah worst like I was
getting beat up left or right I would
kick the bag my my shins would bleed and
I was like I don't want to go back it
was like the hardest [ __ ]
of my life and it was [ __ ] really
hard but after that you know you just
keep at it keep at it and and then I'm
at where I'm at now and I'm now I'm not
like I'm some crazy [ __ ] an amazing
kickboxing or anything like that but
like you know it's after X amount of
years I'm able to look back and be like
okay I've come a long way since where I
started and I think people don't you
know they obviously no-brainer they they
don't get past that first stage because
being uncomfortable is the worst thing
ever for a lot of people doesn't even
like [ __ ] Gilbert by the way Gilbert
this flow you dude today
well that's my face yes that too by the
way which was so weird that you took it
so kindly and so easy you know what easy
I didn't if you look on my Instagram he
puts his ass in my face but I didn't
know I didn't know when I was laying
down I'd even look up yeah sure you
didn't I felt I felt pants you can tell
by the smell he left an ass on your face
yeah [ __ ] straight so there when he
landed the ass cheeks on your face I
heard his anus puckered up and pecked
you yeah and then I kissed my carrots
today huh yeah but [ __ ] Gilbert he
goes like a bro he goes I saw an old
video of you training and he's like you
you were so slow he was like I was so
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] where do you
think I started I was 207 pounds you
[ __ ]
and he's host of that video he he
[ __ ] owned it that's what it is it's
like you gotta own that you suck and
then just know that it'll get better
from there it hasn't because I'm
training with Nick Fury I suck and I'm
worn out
[ __ ] suck at this sport this sport is
the hardest thing I've ever done in my
life because in my mind I'm smooth as
[ __ ] and then they record [ __ ]
and it's like why my hands not up yeah
why not to do that hands right here
that's fine I'm sure Pat could relate to
that like when he watched and Pat is
very good we thought well I've seen it
he's very good but if he were to watch a
video of himself he'd be like man I was
like [ __ ] there I should've got hit by
this Bob yeah it's just that you're
always gonna you're never gonna be
perfect so that's the thing is like I
mean at the more you train the more like
consistent you are and the last mistakes
you make but yeah he's right I'll watch
videos of like me sparring or I'll feel
it in sparring sometimes I beg damn I'm
dropping my hand a lot like and I'll get
pissed at myself
or yeah or the thing that David was
talking about like you think you're the
[ __ ] and this applies to everything
yeah you think you're the dopest [ __ ]
you can be playing basketball you think
oh man I'll [ __ ] cross them off I
look like Luca don't [ __ ] out here but
then you watch look back at taping like
I'll dude I look like absolutely
embarrassed is the worst attitude to
have I think an almost anything like
dude I'm a [ __ ] beast yes especially
even in the beginning like yeah exact
things like that's like you're gonna
give exactly that means you don't do a
lot of things like you understand what
it's like to pick up a new skill like I
can think of all the skills that were
all like the the hobbies that I've
picked up in my life that I've wanted to
pick up and before I did it I was like
oh man I'm gonna [ __ ] smoke this yeah
a lot this is a long time ago but now
I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna suck and I
and I'm like and I'm okay with it you
make peace with it right and that's how
you have to handle something like
fitness or whatever because a lot of the
times it's like I don't say its
romanticized like you think it's gonna
be this big oh man I'm gonna get
shredded I'm gonna get ripped but these
guys that you see that are like ripped
and shredded or these females also like
this took them 5 6 years of training you
know those steroids yeah exactly right
how many people do you know exactly and
how many people do you know that takes
steroids but still look like [ __ ]
they still like me I've been on steroids
for 10 years and it has done nothing
because apparently you have to work out
put your on steroids you just squeeze it
in and that things happen does it help
yes but does it make you look like a
Greek god by not doing that much then I
was like why are you getting fatter with
more pimples and your hair just your
dick can't even get off no but it's just
like yeah people kind of romanticize
things and they don't want to kind of do
the due diligence that's why everybody
went now it's the new year's resolution
time everybody has new year's
resolutions but by [ __ ] January 8th
it's all done exactly you know why cuz I
understand I did a couple of push-ups
today and I'm never going back to the
gym I am [ __ ] sore as [ __ ] and I
understand it's very painful
like even getting through the gym today
was hard I had to take a [ __ ] 20
minute show
I took a 20 minute hot shower just so I
could move my biceps
like please that's a champion he's peace
he's doing the work I think there's
something to be said too about like how
you said it took you a while to lose
weight like I feel like if people that
are trying to do something hard whether
it's learning how to kickbox or lose
weight or whatever the [ __ ] it is like
you're gonna stumble in the beginning
you're gonna fail like you're probably
the first time you try to lose weight
you're not gonna be successful probably
I mean I'm sure it's possible but like
you're gonna probably [ __ ] up and be
like [ __ ] like I only got three weeks
into my diet and like not to beat
yourself up too much just take it as
progress like damn those three weeks
let's see if I could push it to three
and a half weeks or yeah yeah I mean
like cuz I know I felt like that in
certain things I'm doing [ __ ] I just
I'll just quit this I [ __ ] this yeah
it's like you can just flip the
perspective and be like oh no I'll just
actually that was a step in the right
direction yeah yeah because you're
supposed to suck in the beginning what
the [ __ ] yes exactly you suppose good at
everything
you're an [ __ ] that's why I even say
man there's like people that I've like
verbally [ __ ] it on on this podcast and
because they suck at what they do but
I'm not saying that they can't improve
themselves and put some effort in their
life ever become anything and your
mother hates you
yeah and these are all true things these
are all true statements yep yeah your
mother hates you you stupid son of a
[ __ ]
but like I'm saying like there's always
like there's always room for a poop I
could go back and look at my old
stand-up sets which I haven't gotten
that much better but like I look at the
past I'm like is hard and I look at that
oldest clip I'm like damn bro you son
you were so nervous but you know I
always like I have an opinion about
people stand up now but I'm not saying
like they're crappy forever it's just
this my opinion of them now in this
moment you know it's not the best thing
ever yeah there's like people who I
thought were trash and they've gotten so
much better there are people who thought
Bobby Lee was never gonna make it he was
actually told that he should stop doing
comedy and now look at him he's David
did I told him that when I was when I
was like he's like there's only one
Korean around and it's me yeah was a
five year old when I said none that you
should really stop
terrible yeah but he was uh he he was
staying on his podcast I forgot who told
him but it was that a comic was an older
comic that told him that he sucked and
he wasn't good and he should probably
quit yeah he talks about that a lot dude
because I'm sure there's a lot of people
that just [ __ ] on him and they're like
you'll never be funny you know and I'm
sure I'm sure
I don't know I'm I'm sure you've been
through things like that to where like
as a comic like Patrick's on his foot
but I'm sure people have told them
otherwise whether they're just like
Payton or you know they just don't like
his comedy or whatever the [ __ ] it's me
[Laughter]
it's like hey bro still pursuing that
shitty dream of yours that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude I don't I mean our word
you don't use that word remember we
found out that my lord
idiot Lloyd is yeah bro he's polluting
my brain this guy yeah you gotta say
what is the word that we're looking for
[ __ ] dumbass Harden's yep stop being a
cookie dumbass your comedy dreams are
DMS I think I think the only reason why
I like to use the word [ __ ] a lot
because I no longer use the n-word which
I used to use a lot when I was younger
because was a lot more acceptable yeah
so now I'm trying to own the word [ __ ]
and make it as cool as the n-word and I
hop on that too cookies cookies cookie
yeah and when you really like something
you say multiple times really cool you
know what people are so woke like they
won't say [ __ ] which I kind of like it's
very respectful but it's so funny like
when when I did the movie [ __ ] I was we
were walking around with free shirts and
only giving it to white people because
they cook in the front and they would
have take the shirt they're like no I
can't that's so funny you're so woke
broke that was a test
I was really cool of you to not take
this cookie shirt yep I know the
original name of this podcast was
supposed to be Cookie Monster yes
but then I thought I kind of eliminated
like other like racial demographics I
was like I'm gonna take it away but it
was literally a Cookie Monster I [ __ ]
you not with Chinese eyes eating cookie
fortune cookies so who did you pitch
that to and never like David don't do
that something that a couple of my
friends and they're like that's a very
bad idea it was literally just a cookie
monster with Chinese eyes eating fortune
cookies with the fortunes on the floor
and then I don't use that can I use that
I had to do it and he was cracking up
and he thought it was hilarious I bet
when he told Joe he was like yeah that's
that's goes well Joe wasn't originally a
part of this podcast and then I was like
well let's just have somebody else on
here as a consistent and Joe on
that's so really was just genius brain
was just David so and I was like let's
let's bring somebody else in to the mix
man yeah let's make it happen
George it Sakawa and Joe Jitsu Kawa came
along man shout outs to that dude for
just living his life right now that dude
is traveling Joe right now it's just he
just booked a one-way ticket to Europe
and he just was like [ __ ] it let's see
what happened whatever yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy Joe kind of is like a real
free spirit did he go by himself or he
went by himself
Danny met with the ho no he broke up
with his girl yeah yeah they're done
zone no no longer the other guy babe a
single I mean they were together for
five years it's a long time for a long
[ __ ] time this guy's a loop bro yeah
but they but they broke I got you some
more kooky friends dude last time I saw
em they were married bro bro no they
broke up there was like a whole it's so
funny when like YouTube people [ __ ]
break up it's like the biggest deal ever
and it's funny because it's like
everybody breaks up it's the most normal
[ __ ] average thing that everybody
goes through yeah but for some reason
when they see a couple online that
breaks up their dreams shatter yeah yeah
because that's what they look up to
right like I think people watch anybody
who looks up to Jodi Sakawa is a [ __ ]
psychopath anybody listen to me the
psychopath - Joe murders people any
[ __ ] relationship when people are
like super into a relation to real
wedding or what I don't know some
[ __ ] going on with those [ __ ]
idiots like
like why are they famous dude who cares
what's the appeal who cares
cuz people love them the royal family or
whatever I don't know man it's something
dude
funniest three speaking of the royal
family live your life live your life
went through a random rabbit hole of SNL
sketches and there's just one [ __ ] that
they do words I think it's Bill Hader
and Fred Armisen whether he's there like
the royal family it's the Grandma and
Grandpa oh the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they're they're so good together they're
probably the best one of the best and
it's literally them you know they're
like the sweet grandparents of the royal
family and then I think the girl who was
in The Princess Diaries what's her name
Anne Hathaway and Hathaway
beautiful woman I don't like white girls
and that goes pretty a [ __ ] she looks
very elegant pretty maybe not pornstar
pretty but elegant very beautiful which
one do you prefer elegant
I like the elegant ones that looks like
they just don't even know what a dick
they don't even poop don't ya they don't
know what a poop is what's a dick
[Laughter]
it's windy you smell it and they're
flopping all over the place
yeah yeah yeah yeah coming in and then
Anne Hathaway's like it's great meeting
you wha blah blah Prince Henry goes away
and all of a sudden their real
personality comes out they're like you
just want to come here and [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me grandson and just take all the money
not dare you get piece off they're in
snatch so this is a snatch and of course
Fred Armisen is like the [ __ ]
that's the woman he's the [ __ ]
grandma yeah yeah she always plays a
woman hilarious right I love it I want
to be born into wealth and I want to be
rich but I don't want to work for it
royal family baby and that's why people
like the royal family yeah well they
want to be them that's what it is
why they seem so creepy to me they seem
like like when I was I ever see a
picture a magazine at the Friday they
look like creeps like imagine if one of
us had to be in the royal family Oh
like imagine if they would not let this
place chong-in at personality-wise
imagine if his personality was like in
the royal family me them hello mother
hello father you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they
would close the door as I listen I'm not
to take all your money and you can't
stop your daughter loves me [ __ ]
like straight out she loved his Gucci
dick it's not no the weird [ __ ] that she
does I literally take fortune cookie
wrappers I put it on her eyes and I [ __ ]
it from the back and we call that
position the virtue position because
she's just getting a bunch of wisdom
right in her eyes and right through the
ass baby and I'm [ __ ] your daughter
you never thought that China would
invade the UK and there and I'm Korean
but they don't know that okay it's too
much pressure to be a part of a royal
family you can do it oh that's [ __ ] a
royal person I would I would at least
have to at one point say I'm [ __ ] you
in the Royal ass yeah sweetie I'm gonna
say this in sex I know I'm not actually
doing it but I'm [ __ ] you in the
Royal ass [ __ ] me hop sing I hold on
a second okay
whoa I love it I love the slipper
diamond then it my dingus liver
dominance [ __ ] it I hate to you [ __ ]
hey you [ __ ] I don't know as you stop
sticks in here you know what I used to
love is when would whenever something
cuz I don't have a lot of white friends
right but every time I you know in LA a
lot of people here have white friends
that I know usually because the
Sacramento is all black Mexican and
Asian so that's all I grew up with but
every time we would go to an Asian
restaurant and it happens to be like a
wife er they would bring this
[ __ ] would always try to use the
chopsticks to say it's like just use the
fork but he wants to be as respectful as
[ __ ] he goes he had man I [ __ ] love
wontons and he's just over here throwing
gang signs to hold his job steak and I'm
trying not to laugh my hardest and the
like I even be like a mint just use the
fork I'm using a fork I know I love
using chopsticks what do you mean like I
use them all the time it's my favorite
t-bone steaks with these you have you
creating cereal with chopsticks it's the
right
he's like sweating into his [ __ ]
noodles and [ __ ] like that's great you
don't love it dude I don't use
chopsticks that much bro the [ __ ] are
you talking about I use a fork and a
spoon because it's way easier yeah
that's the move like don't do that [ __ ]
man don't you ever walk into my house to
take off your shoes without walking in
with shoes first yeah go sit on my bed
and put your dirty ass shoes on there
and have your seventeen pillows on your
bed which I know that you do and yell at
your mom like it's okay yeah dude that's
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] you Judy yeah the
first time I I hung out with like this
kid it's a high school with and we his
white dude he's like Italian and like
the way he would talk to his mom I was
like I was looking great I was like he's
like you're being such a [ __ ] mom what
the [ __ ] dad you're a dick [ __ ] you and
I was like pets die if his dude wasn't
that cool at all Wow he was next was
pretty cool he invited me over and I was
like okay oh yeah I didn't really have
that many friends dude I hear that [ __ ]
in the old place that I used to live in
in South Pasadena course there is of
course one cousin I'm fancy baby iam
saying live in a condo with five other
guys come on baby ten this podcast don't
make that much come on now more
listeners now yeah they had so it was
his guide he's an archaeologist had a
chat with him of the horn dude of course
okay
of course he's are here on
archaeologists are there any non-white
archaeologists out there common bulla
yes they are they are just dead people
that are buried in the ground and they
are Asian descent so the the dude has
two kids and the walls are kind of thin
so you could hear how the kids talk back
to the parents and it's the [ __ ]
wildest thing because they're they're
like 6 or 7 years old maybe 8 years old
now and I've never in my life as a 8
year old I would have never said the
[ __ ] that they say to their parents and
it's [ __ ] crazy it would be like some
[ __ ] like sweetie I need you to put put
on your jacket it's cold outside you're
not the boss of me
I could wear whatever I want No
we are the boss of you we are your
parents no get out of my round but I'm
like dude just [ __ ] beat your kids
yeah like I want a camera I wanted to
come up to me like dude if you know like
you shouldn't send it to the wall with a
cop in a hole through it you still make
dis to make sure they could hear if
you're like gonna comment those kids
happiness [ __ ] ass yeah honestly in
that situation it's like it's like why
was swinging well I'll be like imma turn
around that click I don't know everybody
was are clapping right I knocked on the
door I walked up to him asking him a
five like this slide it like this right
real quick right but it was a toothbrush
that was made into a knife real quick
come up to the kid like you had
passenger a doughnut be like hey you
hungry for breakfast long blood and then
sign of the doughnut happy smiles it
real quick okay Colgate like I wouldn't
know what to do it might get screaming
at the top of their lungs and me I think
I would keep them in the face it would
be really hard not to yeah like one dude
it's just quick just to like resent
respect back like we need to go back to
baseline yeah yeah cuz you're getting
crazy that's it my life is like I wanted
to tell him like dude like if you socked
up your kid I would tell the cops that
you're the nicest person I ever met and
that's impossible
not easy nothing with that I would back
you up my [ __ ] roommate was so funny
because he would hear those kids scream
at their parents at the top of their
lungs and like 5 a.m. in the morning so
they on Christmas Day they had like a
note on the mailbox mailbox to give the
Santa and he opened it up read it and
it's like Santa we've been really good
and we want if he's [ __ ] tore
it up that's why we have [ __ ] kids
you know just roam the streets and they
turn into [ __ ] adults I think all
kids need to get beat up at least once
in their life do by their parents but
like in the street or something you need
hit by somebody to understand how this
likeable time there's repercussions when
you're being a [ __ ] [ __ ] throws
that's why I only pick on people smaller
than me yes all day Jason Chan Wow Jason
champ you have any idea how many times I
[ __ ] people up but I made sure they
didn't see my face and they were 10
years younger
she was tight now did it it's true like
you needed some you need to get smacked
at least a couple times when you get
your ass beat it humbles you bring back
people I know they they've never been
punch in the face before see that's
crazy yeah that's crazy
maybe they are the [ __ ] yes you can
tell by the way that they talk to you
when they come up to you and especially
when you check them in you're like well
let's [ __ ] throw down there like bro
I'm just joking sorry dudes like you've
never been punched you for a fact have
never been socked in the face right
because I always and even even like
Mariel when I tell her I realize that
was really bad punched but I come a
scenario right and I'm like listen I
ain't trying to put that toilet seat
down as she goes guess what women's rule
the world and I slaps her in the face
quick right I just give her that couple
that that four knuckle treatment you
know I'm saying dude I said and then she
looks at me she's like I'm just joking
bro and I might welcome to the hood
homey yeah and then you went yeah I
think a hairpin that she has right I
take it off and I take my knife
sharpener just small enough where I
won't be like to bottle up the Sun
beater with the ice melts away no but
she'll see me I get angry at situations
at people who act like [ __ ] and then
she's like why do you do that it's like
because I want this person to know that
they can get away with this right cuz I
think that she gets mad at me about that
stuff too yeah cuz they be always
wanting I'm not saying I'm like
confrontation or anything but I have to
you have to realize how rude and
disrespectful you have to be to me for
me to get actually get angry yeah and
that's the thing is sometimes in certain
saying like blow up over any little yeah
don't do that and stuff but like they're
not cool there's certain times where
people are being asked
were like you can tell that no one said
anything to him that's and they're gonna
continue to be this way so you have to
[ __ ] tell him have you had a story
like that like by parking anywhere yeah
I mean yeah I've gotten I've gotten in
like little arguments of people and show
like that but but like just like dive a
little deeper now you want me to tell
this story this is one of my favorites
isn't that crazy it's just that like I
was going on I said this guy was being a
dick and he thought he was uh he thought
he can get away with it but being a dick
for no reason so so I parked my car I
was going to a coffee shop O's parked I
parked my car and as I'm walking to the
coffee shop I hear a voice behind me be
like hey like I just go hey hey hey so I
turn around like what the [ __ ] and some
guy standing on his porch and he has
like these two like Latino dudes like
working on like painting his house or
whatever and he's like hey like you
can't park here and I was like okay like
okay so I start I walk us to walking
back to my car was in a movement car and
as I'm about to open the door he's like
hey he's like how about the next time
you parked somewhere I suggest you read
the signs and I was like yes what race
he was Blanco el wydo wydo it is late
40s early 50s so you go how about you
how about I suggest you read the science
I was like how about you go [ __ ]
yourself and he was like freaking out
yeah you started tripping and I just
started cussing him out I was like
you're a [ __ ] old [ __ ] like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] just like going on if I
ever does that
I thought the you know dudes were like
looking they looked at me but they were
smiling like yeah and he was like what'd
he say he was like well I have to tell
people all the time I was like I don't
give a [ __ ] like I was moving my car you
piece of [ __ ] like you'd have to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I was leaving yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] got what you wanted
right he's like well I got no and then
how did I told him I was like you know
what man I was well I just was getting
in my cars like man I wanted to beat his
[ __ ] ass but I was like this guy
definitely looks like he's gonna press
charges I can't hit him and I'm
literally walking onto his property this
is vagrant yeah it's not even a word
this is just pure insulting yeah pure so
so I [ __ ] I'm getting him a karma you
know I might go [ __ ] yourself and he was
like you know what you two good comeback
dumb
[Laughter]
this will turn into a [ __ ] used-car
lot [ __ ] balloon how much you wanna
bet he went into his house and he was
like idiot I shouldn't have done that
oh for sure that guy was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and his response is like you
know what you're in your 50 of doing
that like relax argument I was um I was
[ __ ] oh I had this whole situation
where so basically Southwest they [ __ ]
up my flight and of this story they
booked they booked me for this flight
took my money I had to fight there and
no stealin play so by the way I was
already sick I kind of had a fever [ __ ]
just like on the right when I was about
to have the flu and all I said was this
like I wasn't yelling I was just like I
was like what the [ __ ]
yeah me and this lady who I wasn't even
talking to wasn't the agent and she just
goes she'll sir you need to watch your
language
I was like whoa what the [ __ ] was with
this aggression right yeah I was like yo
like I'm not cursing at anybody on my
family so I said I'm allowed to be upset
like you guys just stole 250 bucks for
me like like I'm allowed to be upset
yeah and this dude other guy comes he
goes we got a problem here he was listen
your son I'll make sure that you'll
never that you will not go back home to
see your family for the holidays what
the [ __ ] and I have a fever right now
yeah and I'm getting pissed but then in
my mind I'm like you know you could say
that because if I say some [ __ ] back to
you you'll call security they'll take me
out and I'll miss my flight and I won't
be able to go back home for Christmas
and not get reimbursed exactly and
that's the smallest amount of power that
he had to be an [ __ ] and he knew that
[ __ ] so he goes do you understand me I
literally was just like gripping the
[ __ ] a table at that and I just like
stared at him and he was you understand
me I just wouldn't respond I just kept
looking at him and he goes we got it
wouldn't say anything I just kept
staring until he walked away and the
only thing I was thinking I can't swing
at the dude I can't tell him to [ __ ] off
because I won't be able to go home and
so I just sat there and I was like I'm
gonna do what white people do complain
went on Twitter message Southwest and
then I gave
guy's name who he was and the whole
situation and then he got represented
and then I got a hundred bucks nice so
I'm like I just said that and I was like
what the [ __ ] was his deal yeah like no
first of all I wasn't even talking to
you I didn't scream I was like what the
[ __ ] he's trying to he's trying to be a
white knight bro this dude's trying to
come in exactly and save this girl you
don't want me anymore
my [ __ ] was like a six-foot to black
inside no you know what's up man like
come on man you can't be doing this to
me like come on
he's like why are you talking like yeah
as I bro I'm the white is like come on
brother what's good I was like I went to
I went to [ __ ] the Bahamas last week
I'm just a really bald white guy no but
this guy was just in my face about that
[ __ ] and I just refused to apologize and
I just kept staring at him and after he
just left I just stood there
pissed because I didn't know what to say
I was like you can't say anything yes
duck here I said to take that [ __ ] and
the only thing to do was report him and
then it's it's it's it's customer
service dude yeah and I wasn't even mad
at them I was just like what the [ __ ]
like that lady couldn't understand why
you were mad and upset yeah you know you
took my money
yeah right like I'm allowed to be a mad
at you actually like oh I can't find
your seat and afterwards - I was like
you do know that I wasn't upset he goes
it's okay sir so I was like well of
course it's okay I wasn't cursing at you
like I wasn't mad at you I was like I'm
let you know I'm gonna report you
but that dude you can get reported ya
know like okay any you're right I think
it's the power trip thing yeah just sees
an avenue for him to just be a dick and
he's like I just feel like [ __ ] with
this guy and that's it the big ass dude
- I was like bro I have no problem sock
you in the face like you look like you
could take it so let's see like the
situation where it's like like we're two
adults consenting let's just fist fight
for a little bit yeah no cops let's see
what [ __ ] like the hooks guy's in Hawaii
you bro yeah dawg yo everybody out there
on the podcast world do yourself a favor
and look up 808 scraps 808 is Hawaii or
Oahu's area code why the [ __ ] does
everybody know how to fight like it's
like MMA they all do bro can they scrap
and like technical - they're not even
like being it's like the best UFC fight
you'll ever see on the street yeah
everybody it's Kelvin Gastelum verse
Topman are all like even it was you
could tell like they don't really train
they just know how to throw yeah they're
just
know how to throw really [ __ ] well in
their blood right like they're all
fighter [ __ ] like yeah first
time I ever went to Hawaii at a bar
these two dudes I don't even know what
they're fighting about all I heard was
this you want beef brah brah you want me
a bun let's go let's take it outside bro
they go outside I might of course me
being the the nosy man I said what I
went outside just to see what's
happening dawg they were throwing blows
full clip at each other and this full
cracks the guy don't know what it was a
little bit but what the cross our hook
whatever cuz it was just so exciting
yeah
cracks it dude he falls over he starts
pummeling the guy and everybody he's
good he's good he's done he's done he
got some you got you could you go talk a
[ __ ] comes up picks him up this gives
him deaf they go as like he buys him a
beer that's done like that's what it's
about
yeah because they squash his leg we
squash his squash is good yeah and they
squash the move on bottom a beer and it
was we was whatever I'm not sure it's
that if that's typical of Hawaii but I
know that a bunch of MOS which is like I
guess their version of like Hawaiian
Hillbillies or some [ __ ]
Byam Oaks like they throw down they
throw down and after they squash and
they move on that's the coolest [ __ ]
ever yeah that's what needs to have
because it really shows like if you're
gonna talk that [ __ ] you better be able
to back it up exactly and if you're not
gonna back it up
shut the [ __ ] up and move on exactly you
better be ready for that type of the
mutual combat law in Seattle I think
they still have it they still have it
yes like that's that's what's up dude
like cop shows up if there's really a
problem the cop turns into a [ __ ] UFC
referee yep and like it's like you want
to fight yeah do you want to fight yeah
and then you guys are a little like a
couple minutes oh yeah get out of your
system and then everyone goes home or if
the guy doesn't want to fight you just
he goes nah and it's like [ __ ] it
whatever yeah I mean that dudes a [ __ ]
for sure exactly but like whatever like
but the but like there needs to be some
accountability for you being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you're gonna be an [ __ ] or
if you're ready to talk like I don't
talk [ __ ] to people unless I'm willing
to go there because I understand that
calling somebody a [ __ ] like this dude
might hit me in the face I don't know
who the [ __ ] I'm calling yeah [ __ ] so
it's like I don't but I don't do that
often because I'm not trying to fight
with people but am i if you do hear me
calling somebody a [ __ ] no
that I am willing to go there because
I've already I've stepped into this zone
yeah a lot of people step into that zone
and are like why did you hit me yeah cuz
you just called me a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
yeah now I'm slapping you because this
you've crossed that line so now this is
how I reacted to this line being crossed
you know I think like the hardest part
for me when I was when I was younger too
cuz yeah I was just a [ __ ] fat asian
kid yeah and people just talk [ __ ] their
tests chip and then it's like I would
sock them in the face cuz it was physics
just because like I grew up getting
bullied so I was like it my thing was
this if you were gonna bully me I was
gonna make it the hardest person to
bully ever yeah I mean like I'm just
gonna keep swinging at you and you might
beat me up or you might jump me with a
bunch of people but every time you do it
I'm gonna make it [ __ ] different I
gotta go somewhere else so like it was
it was so weird where I you know I don't
think people understand like when you
grow up in a bad area either you have
you either you throw down or just get
pumped for the rest of your life yeah
and there's certain people that you
don't talk back because they'll kill you
but just general people who try to bully
you some people you know they got big
goddamn bangs on them and they come up
and they're like listen here you fat
[ __ ] and I'm like yeah yeah I'm a [ __ ]
you know but a lot of the times like it
was like I think I used to get bullied a
lot so she's like [ __ ] it
like let's just throw down let's just
see what happens funny [ __ ] story
by the way they so weird well I don't
recollect certain things until you know
people bring it up from the past so my
cousin was telling me this story could
we were talking and he goes you remember
back in the day we used to live in the
duplexes so we used to live in this
duplex area called a temp woods and it
was like super hood back in the day
there was like a bunch of Samoan bloods
that lived on one Street it was just a
really bad area but there was a point
where a bunch of kids in the
neighborhood were just [ __ ] throwing
down it's just like this all-out brawl
and remember this is what lady in the
corner just any pink starburst is why
yeah right but we were telling the story
and I was like yeah remember that part
where we're that kid brought out a knife
and then everybody's scared cause he's
got stabbed people
bro that kid was you remembered it being
somebody else Wow he was like you are
the one that went into the house and
then you brought out a knife and you
were gonna stab [ __ ] and you
scared everybody off yeah I was like nah
sounds like you he was I was like nah
that wasn't me he goes no but I was
telling the story as if I was witnessing
the crazy kid brought the knife do you
fight clubbed yourself yeah I don't
remember that though shut your mouth but
he said he goes like no a hundred
percent that was you he goes I remember
that [ __ ] because you were the one that
scared everybody away because you're
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] you were just gonna
stab people I was like eight years old
Wow I went to a Mexican funeral and then
they did the rosary thing I don't know
it's like a Catholic thing yes Rosario
and like they would say like a chant
over no I don't know what it's called
Mary's in the Our Father
yeah and like you kept having to stand
up and I was the only yellow person
there and I was just like if people
would stand up and I was like oh [ __ ]
have to stand up and then come back down
up down up down and they kept saying
fruit that the hisui I don't know that's
the only part I remember because Jesus
Jesus fruit the fruit of Jesus for Jesus
I never heard that but yeah yeah I think
you are making things up and I think you
felt get TIFF here now bro you know she
was Jesus is a fruit but like talking
about like really good fight stories
Patrick has a story about how like hey
man just cut the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
enough about my Spanish but like Patrick
has a really good story about how this
guy came to his house or something like
that and oh this guy tried to run up on
pat pat this story he he had kicked him
or something and he looked at him he
said if you ever come back to my house
again because the guy was like lurking
around his house he said if you ever
come back to my house again
I'm gonna break something on your
[ __ ] body right this guy comes back
to his house
Patrick punched him in the nose and
broke his [ __ ] nose yes is the guy
let me fight with like five different
people
you kid has gotten so many [ __ ] fights
no I haven't I haven't been that many
but I'd like not provoked by him
people try to pick on him I haven't I
haven't honestly I haven't I've only
been in like six fight that's not really
a lot of fights I mean I but I on the
streets my thing is is that like my I
just I look I look like weak I look like
I don't look like a fighter I look like
somebody you could pick also you're very
nice take advantage of that [ __ ] and so
they want to test and that but that's
what makes me mad is because I know what
I look like and I know that if I look
differently like they wouldn't be doing
the same thing for me too I think that
that's pisses me off so much cuz it's
like dude I know if I look different or
if I was like a buff dude like you
wouldn't be saying that yeah so that
should drive that like little bully [ __ ]
like [ __ ] drives me crazy like
condescending type of [ __ ] - yeah what's
just like you it's like a you're just a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz like I you know I don't treat people
that I think I could pick on like [ __ ]
because I'm not an [ __ ] and I want to
treat people nice everybody nice you
know so cool about your story your story
is that I don't like the way these
people perceive me so I'm gonna [ __ ]
them up my story is you're gonna bully
me but I'm just gonna make it really
difficult I didn't win the exchanges I'm
just like it's gonna be a rough night
for you guys that's good that's good I
mean whatever you can [ __ ] do man I
use people I just scratch eyes dude yeah
whatever whatever it was it was kind of
cool though cuz it was like I was always
that dude in the group hey they're just
like babies gonna get mad do you know
because I think it was and I would
always get mad more over other people's
situations in my home so it would be
like Oh homie like something's happening
I'm like leave my friend alone and I
guess starting getting [ __ ] angry and
I just you should take the bull you know
I can be like I'll be fine yeah I got
beat up a lot too at the same time by
just getting beat up yeah I wish I had
in foreknowledge I had now 10 years ago
cuz everybody up but then you wouldn't
have that many stories if you're getting
picked on you'd only have one yeah just
be me picking other people yeah yeah I
know what it feels like so I'm ready to
get to you
yeah ya know I once a bullied a kid once
and didn't like it because I wanted to
be on the other side of it and there was
this kid what did you do what did you do
well there was there's this kid really
geeky kid he actually trans transfer
schools I made
men's with him cuz I actually apologized
to him after because I was so sick of
getting bullied and I was getting too
bonsai okay he's escaped I was like
what's it feel like on the other side so
he put this kick me sign on this kid and
people actually kick the [ __ ] out of
this cat like they literally started
stomping this kid and I thought give him
a couple said and I look back and I was
like this feels terrible
yeah I felt so bad and so afterwards
like I remember he was like sitting on
this this fence at recess just sitting
there just in a corner and I went up to
I sat down like I said I was like some
myself which I gave to him si si cool
man they're [ __ ] I said they're
[ __ ] B he couldn't tell ya I didn't
apologize to my stone they're [ __ ]
but he had your footprints [ __ ] head
here's the crazy [ __ ] so after this it's
crazy because that was the moment where
I [ __ ] knew I couldn't be the other
bully on the other side and I hated it
so much so I think got into a lot of
trouble because I kept backing up that
kid after that because they would try to
Punk him and I was step in and I was
this geeky little fat kid I start
swinging on people and so people didn't
understand this story that everybody
knows on this podcast where I when I was
in third grade I stabbed the kid in the
[ __ ] face with a pencil I know that
story literally sticketh pencil I shoved
it right through his mouth and took me
outside oh really when it went all the
way through so he had to get stitches
inside so yeah oh it was just that
situation of getting Punk'd and bullied
over so many times I had to go extreme
which I just I don't remember I remember
that situation like it was yesterday
because it's like burned in my memory
but basically what happened was I people
were throwing spitballs in class and
while the the teacher was doing math
problems a [ __ ] he got hit upside his
head he thought it was me because I was
cracking up laughing I was dying
laughing Clarys yeah and so he comes up
and he pushes me out of my chair and I
just go read and I was writing [ __ ] so I
already had this [ __ ] in my head and you
know the kid moved to do is hammer fist
maybe a yeah so I started hammer fisting
this full and then I got him right in
the face
right through the mouth and then uh I
didn't know that happened until he
stopped and he's like she started
screaming and then blood was coming out
on his face and then the principal asked
you what happened you're like yes I'm
kid Tyler
the face like what happened I was like I
pinched him that was my response I said
I pinched him and the lo and behold what
happens his older brother comes and he
beats me up the next day and then the
principal comes in and then he suspends
the older brother for doing that [ __ ]
but I got into two more fights after
that and I had to get him removed from
the school so I didn't suspend because
people would bully me like I said I was
gonna make it really hard for you to
[ __ ] bully me yeah and crazy always
beats everything else wasn't a great
fighter but I would always swing it's
funny cuz like now when I look back and
I talk about like these fights as a kid
and junior high and high school it's
like I was a terrible fighter I think we
all just like the fighting which is just
through yeah you know why in style foo
yeah it's crazy like what a little bit
of fight knowledge would have done for
me know if I just had it back there yeah
oh yeah especially the ground like if
you knew any jiu-jitsu at all yeah or
like grappling over like tape it would
just been over but I didn't know that
[ __ ] we would just start swinging and
whoever got the hit first was the winner
right but that's that's that almost
cooler because that means like you were
willing to go out and shield to give a
[ __ ] I because what like if you go out
willing to [ __ ] fight people and you
know that I know more than you do like
the last time I had a situation in high
school where somebody was pissing me off
there's a world there's a girl world
there's a girl named Sarah she was a
Mormon chick been friends with her says
elementary school I remember her because
when I first transferred over from a
different elementary school cuz I
stabbed that kid she was one of my first
friends very sweet girl right I love her
to death we became friends in junior
high then in high school we were friends
- she needed a locker buddy she decided
to become a locker buddy with me we were
standing in line it was taking like two
hours to get this locker we're waiting
up there and there's one cholo Mexican
do slicked back hair like maybe like a
couple inches taller than me but really
kind of skinny and God he comes up I
[ __ ] you not
grabs my paper tosses it aside and this
is this the the the permission slip to
get a locker toss his size steps in
front of me he goes and he puts his
paper in I'm like [ __ ] I literally grab
his [ __ ] I was like this your paper and
it was his friend standing next to him I
was like - a locker partner
I [ __ ] snatched the [ __ ] and I tore
that [ __ ] up I was like you gotta get
your [ __ ] tomorrow and then people knew
me has a really goofy class clown yeah
but then like cuz I never got into fight
in school right cuz you know my parents
would know and I would get I'll get my
ass beat my that would beat the living
[ __ ] out of me so I
this [ __ ] I wrote what I was wearing - I
was wearing some baby blue Jordan shorts
a long white TV
shaaka [ __ ] cap leather cap homie
Heather yup with my dick out
come on some white Air Force Ones homie
and it's funny because I was such a nice
goofy dude Chris and I was like looks
thick glasses and [ __ ] whatever whatnot
just look like a normal [ __ ] kid in
four in high school and that Duke came
up to me step that's me and the only
thing I kept saying and I was about to
swing on this kid and I just feel this
gentle little hand just grabbed me and
it was [ __ ] the Mormon girl Sarah she
goes David please don't and I'm like
[ __ ] like I'm not and I literally just
told him and I walk up to his face I
said touch me and see what happens
that's all I just kept saying I was like
touch me and see what happens then of
course in high school the perfect circle
forms yeah and everybody's like oh come
on the dude in choir yeah they know me I
was like the Asian do that sings R&B
music like that was like touch me and
see what happens because I wanted to
murder this guy because of the amount of
disrespect yeah because I felt that way
it's like you saw this chubby asian kid
with glasses and you were gonna tear up
my [ __ ] and just push me aside get away
with it right and just get away with it
yes i lo maja I've been bullying my
whole life dude I'm gonna [ __ ] murder
you huh you're the default you're the
perfect sub I was just like the bully
guy and they just he was I [ __ ] this
[ __ ] he just walked away
I was literally gonna murder that dude I
was so [ __ ] mad yeah but like that
was that feeling that I had growing up
all the time like people think that I am
just this [ __ ] pushover they're gonna
rob me then I take my [ __ ] which
happened when I was a kid to people like
[ __ ] took my money you know cuz I was
that fat little Asian kid in the block
and they would jack my [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
hated that [ __ ] so I was like you know
what as I get older I'm just gonna go
[ __ ] crazy when I was in high school
- one of the homies gave me a gun now
it's like let's see what happens never
used it I said o'clock put it in this
little thing oh I think my dad actually
found it and he threw it away but he's
never mentioned it because when I went
when I went to college and I came back I
couldn't find the gun where do you throw
it just in the trash I don't know his
disposal how do you get rid of gun I
don't know because I heard of the Rings
I had two Glocks I returned one back to
the homie and then the other one I had
in the house and I
I used to live in the back area we
called it the shed but it's my dad built
like this back house area and I you and
I put it there under the shelf in a box
and I think my when I came back it was
gone
so my dad threw it away for sure either
he thought it was a fake gun or he just
no station he just tossed it away yeah
yeah yeah
damn yeah [ __ ] crazy well I got some
crazy stories bro what time is it man
how much we in it's an hour 18 in hell
yeah
yeah well that wraps a regular
interphase now I was supposed to go up
again we didn't talk [ __ ] about Ricky
Gervais he's great that's legend there's
nothing else you can say off that you
know that's right Dukey dicks baby
looky big that's right that's a podcast
Dukie do what's this trio that we call
here Doogie dick trio be big Trio is on
the podcast baby now we're the Cookie
Monster's Cookie Monster's we the Cookie
Monster's hashtag share your Dookie dick
story yeah pictures post pictures and
I'm gonna make an emotional youtube
video where it's just two people staring
at each other across the first time I
put it in your ass it was a horrific
experience I don't have headphones on
and they can't hear it that's a great
short film dude I'm down black and white
violin in the back from the water wind
[ __ ] Sundance for sure dude he takes
the next Paris 2020 parasite - Patrick
where can they find you my Instagram my
name Patrick Tuohey Riley find all my
stuff
yeah you need to start posting more [ __ ]
by the way I do 2020 is a year that you
promote yourself
I can't I'm not gonna ride that I can't
Nick the ear on Instagram and YouTube
yeah if you want to commit to him for
personal training yeah hit me up if you
guys have any questions or you know need
some advice on some new year's
resolution stuff
hit me up yep I'll be healthy I'll be
healthy
I'll be happy to help you out all right
and you got mine David David so comedy
dot-com which I want to change that
because I'm not a comic anymore
he's still pretty fun I try and I
understand to be in I got two shows in
February so I guess I still yeah we're
in Jersey in New York but I'll be out
there
Shay already you know it is baby a doing
that stand by my
I say crazy [ __ ] haha
Spotify stitcher podcast iTunes whatever
five stars leave comments below in Iraq
say what's up see y'all next time tell
them about the podcast peace